(mellow music)
- [Phone Recording] DailyVee
and AskGaryVee Show.
- Fantastic city.
To the citizens of Asia as a whole,
I'm excited about our
relationship over the next decade.
(calm electronic music)
- I want to really, really focus on Asia.
So we have to have a conversation.
Basically what I want to
get through the system
is either you believe in me or you don't.
Because that's how we win.
That's how we go fast.
You know, like, I'm just
gonna do whatever is right,
and I'm so confident in what my energy is.
I know how I look at it, you know?
So just positivity.
That's, that's, that's,
positivity and optimism.
That's the currency.
- I just wanted to come say "thank you".
And I'm ultimately like,
You are great at wine.
I believe it was just yesterday,
we were sitting there,
opening up like 50 bottles
at a steakhouse somewhere
I'm going, "we're wine-o-viniacs,""
and you're getting just better at this,
and it's just priceless.
And it's been priceless to me.
I actually think you underestimate
your value.
You're out there talking to entrepreneurs,
but for me,
I get to speak personally
on a daily basis,
especially in the last two years,
the inspiration and the assertion,
affirmation that I get from you,
you know Michael Phelps will
put on his headphones before he goes in,
I'm queuing up, scrubbing through,
finding DailyVees quotes
before I'm walking down the
street to go into the office
or before I'm headed into a meeting.
It's been powerful for me
and it's really made a difference in
the way I manage my day-to-day.
- I appreciate that.
To your point,
I think people,
I'm scared to say,
to actually articulate how
much I don't underestimate it.
I know exactly what's happening.
I think I haven't even started.
Is this the next meeting?
- Yeah.
- They were given to me a long time ago,
and I was in my closet,
and I was like,
you know, if I wear these today,
they feel very, like
I came from Hong Kong.
My energy is going to be the same,
which is to maximize the happiness
and the impact of all
the best players, right?
If you're trying to hire those two
junior video people,
you just need to look for hustle, speed,
religion, and look at the work.
The people that know how to do it
are kind of doing it
by themselves at home.
I couldn't find anybody for Vanoo Media.
I just hired people,
ran them through it,
and some worked and some didn't.
Cool.
- Asia, huh?
- Uh, Asia.
We just need to figure this out, dude.
There's just so much goodness going on.
There's a lot of things
that we don't talk about
that make it scary.
Which is why I don't like
the current state of
entrepreneurship in the world
because it seems very party,
and popular,
and cool,
and it is literally everything but.
I started my daily vlog.
Yes, I like attention and I want selfies,
but much more.
Because I want people to
see how hard it really is.
How long every day is
if you wanna be successful.
And so,
I'm scared of everything.
Which actually ironically
means I'm scared of nothing.
- And when you say "growth happy",
- Somebody who has the ability
to understand what is
trying to be accomplished,
and then know all the triggers
that are under priced
in a digital landscape
to make them happen.
I think event marketing is
the great growth hack of life.
I really do.
It's why all my energy is
going that direction right now.
When you think of the
ROI of event marketing,
event marketing
should be profitable business development.
2018, we are going to be
the best modern day media company.
We're gonna do everything right.
This is what I always tell the team,
it's so frantic,
like there's so much going on,
but sometimes you gotta take a step back
and think about the
fact that we literally,
we bought you in January.
I've got it. Like, I'm
seeing it now, you know?
So, that's all.
Just think about a lot
of different things.
But the wine thing for sure.
I'm pumped. It's real.
It's gonna work.
- [Camera Person] You guys ready?